et le mépris de l'autre c'est ça qui est
presque on a une bonne conscience au
milieu de ses contradictions quand on
dénonce le capitalisme qu'on défend la
morale dans le capitalisme et qu'on
écrit dans tous les journaux qui
défendent le capital j'écris j'écris
dans challenges que d'un journal de
gauche libération même que le nouvel obs
amis quand même pas le tournant du grand
patronat et par ailleurs je ne condamne
pas le capitalisme à ce que je dis c'est
que le capitalisme est amoral puisqu'il
fonctionne à l'égoïsme
mais c'est bien pourquoi ils
fonctionnent si fort autrement dit le
capitalisme marche d'autant plus qu'en
effet il fonctionne l égoïsme et que
l'égoïsme et la principale force motrice
simplement il faut rappeler que
l'égoïsme c'est formidable pour créer de
la richesse
ça n'a jamais suffi à faire une
civilisation et que cela suffit à faire
une société qui soit humainement qu'est
ce que doit faire le citoyen normal
aujourd'hui comme ordinaire il doit
faire la politique est ce que c'est une
sagesse de faire d'une certaine façon de
la politique
en tout cas une action comme comme lui
il va évidemment faire de la politique
et contrairement à tartas locret à la
tarte à la crème qui nous parle de crise
de valeurs de crise morale ce n'est pas
vrai la morale en france se porte plutôt
bien
est ce qu'on appelle le politiquement
correct est très souvent un moralement
correct
moi j'ai envie de dire aux gens parler
un peu moins de morale et un peu plus de
politique
la france ne va pas bien ce ne sont pas
les bons sentiments qui vont la faire
sortir de la crise dans laquelle elle
s'enferre depuis plusieurs décennies
vous avez quelque chose à lui oui ne la
faisons fi que que vous prenez n'est pas
enseignée à l'école
comment ça se fait elle est enseignée à
l'école basuyaux team pas cette manière
là alors après sur chaque mètre et ses
professeurs et est libre de sa pédagogie
moi je sais j'en reçois beaucoup de
lettres de collège mais qui s'excuse
auprès de moi parce qu'ils ne cessent de
photocopier tel ou tel de mes textes
mody sy qui paraissait sur deux vous
péremptoire qui distille des conseils
des réprimandes et cetera vous n'êtes
jamais gagnée par le doute comme venus
elle n'est pas le doute et en vérité je
suis pas péremptoire ma jeune fan de
leçon à personne ça me frappe toujours
quand on m'interroge sur une question
d'actualité
ma première réaction est presque
toujours de perplexité me souviens d'un
d art et que j'ai pas repris dans ce
recueil là mais sur la première guerre
en irak le monde me demande un article
sur ce que je pense je fais un article
posté quête je suis perplexe je me
couche je comprends très bien de ce soir
n'a pas retenu l'argument de ceux qui
désirent suivre jour après on n'écrit
pas un article pour faire état de sa
perplexité
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait faux et du
coup évite de me prononcer en permanence
sur telle ou telle question d'actualité
encore une fois c'est un texte de
philosopher ce n'est pas un texte
militants ce que j'essaye d'apporter
c'est un éclairage philosophie qui est
bien loin d'être de la longue et plutôt
effectivement le plus souvent du côté du
doute est interrogé un chapitre sur
l'ecclésiaste certains postes
effectivement la question si toutes les
vanités y compris la sagesse à quoi bon
écrire publier édité faire le rappeur à
quoi bon philosophe et monsieur le
philosophe n'a pour le plaisir et la
joie qu'on y trouve et c'est de la leçon
même de l'ex diable pour moi c'est le
plus beau texte de la bible
l'un des plus beaux textes de tous les
temps vanité des vanités tout est vanité
mais la conclusion c'est prend plaisir à
la vie avec la femme que tu aimes c'est
une leçon de joie de plaisir je dirai au
delà du désespoir et c'est pourquoi ce
texte m'a toujours paru bouleversant on
retient la leçon un rostre et vous tous
capacités encore montaigne pour terminer
c'est tout un programme
il s'agit de bien faire l'homme ou de
bien faire l'homme où la femme
il s'agit de faire bien l'homme et du
mans c'est à dire sans oublier de faire
quand nécessaire son devoir
merci à vous tous c'est ça le goût de
vivre et c'est ce qu'on prenne les
fidèles qui nous regardent cette
émission bibliothèque médicis à travers
le monde
et l'équipe de bibliothèque médicis
anne-marie moreau philippe lallemand à
la réalisation oriane jean cour céline
révéler qu est un as markovic le goût de
vivre
si j'avais un gros bruit c'est à dire
une sagesse laïque qui a du plaisir agir
qui accepte le risque et l'action et qui
vit soit vous l'aimez à l'espérance qui
vit dans normand l'amour et la volonté
valent mieux que l'espérance
ouais mais qui vivent sans illusion on
espère que ce qu'il n'est pas on aime
que ce qui est on espère que ce qui
n'était pas pas de nous on ne veut que
ceux qui en dépend voilà désirons un peu
moins ceux qui n'étaient pas pas de nous
un peu plus ce qui est et ce qui dépend
de nous il s'agit d'apprendre à vouloir
et à aimer comme disaient les saynètes
et les stoïciens merci à vous tous
à bientôt
oui
vous
publicsenat.fr devient le portail de
l'information politique
dès à présent vous pouvez suivre
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
en temps réel converser réagissent et
participer à tous les contenus du site
est toujours la chaîne public sénat en
direct 24 heures sur 24 comme l'ensemble
de vos émissions en vod en accès gratuit
et illimité jour et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo en
compagnie d'emmanuel kessler bonjour
emmanuel nous faire un tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine dont voici les temps forts
tout d'abord les cadeaux fiscaux aux
plus favorisés vont ils être grignoté
pas question toucher au bouclier fiscal
a répété le ministre françois baroin
devant la commission des finances de
l'assemblée
en revanche devant les sénateurs
françois fillon n'a pas exclu de s'en
prendre aux niches fiscales et l'elysée
envisage un prélèvement spécifique pour
payer les retraites
la double peine des sinistrés de la
tempête xynthia une carte noire des
zones inondables a été présenté par les
préfets de vendée et de
charente-maritime près de 1500 maisons
vont être détruites sur le littoral
atlantique les maires conteste l'ampleur
de ces démolitions d'annoncer enfin les
rumeurs qui empoisonnent les couloirs de
l'elysée qui a bien pu lancer des bruits
sur la vie privée des sarkozy y at il eu
enquête de police pour débusquer les
responsables
deux femmes sont montés au créneau cette
semaine rachida dati et carla bruni
sarkozy elle même le retour sur cette
affaire très privée devenue imbroglio
public est notre invité cette semaine
c'est martine billard bonjour alors vous
êtes député de paris élu en 2002 sous la
couleur ou les couleurs des verts votre
ancien parti malgré le décollage de
l'écologie depuis les airs européenne et
bien vous en avait claqué la porte des
verres en vous opposant à la stratégie
de daniel cohn bendit trop ouvertes au
centre selon vous avez donc rejoint
juillet dernier le parti de gauche de
jean luc mélenchon dont vous êtes la
porte parole à l'assemblée nationale
vous êtes membre de la commission des
affaires sociales vos sujets de
prédilection la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
la défense de la carte scolaire ou
encore on le verra la politique de
l'immigration
juste une question peut-être pour
commencer celle qu'on vous pose tout le
temps vous sentez vous à l'aise dans
votre nouvelle famille politique
l'écouté je me sens tout à fait à l'aise
je ne connais pas les verts je vais me
regarder absolument pas c'est un choix
de conviction puisque je suis parti au
lendemain du résultat des européennes
donc je savais pertinemment cité un
résultat ce qui est alors moi j'ai
trouvé positif du point de vue de
l'écologie simplement je suis
effectivement total désaccord avec
l'orientation prise par europe écologie
de repositionnement au centre il est
critique que je portais ouvert pour
lesquelles j'ai mené des batailles en
interne sont toujours là c'est à dire le
fait que les verts savent pas prendre en
compte la question sociale et s'occupent
comme ils disent souvent des plus
fragiles pour moi là c'est pas une
question de plus fragiles ce n'est pas
un problème de d'êtres humains fragiles
ou pas fragile saint prime de deux choix
politique un problème de type de société
et donc je me sens beaucoup mieux parti
de gauche et je dois dire qu
intellectuellement c'est beaucoup plus
satisfaisant est plus stimulant aussi
beaucoup plus
réflexion régionale l'hypothèse d'une
alliance entre les verts et les
centristes du modem par exemple c'est
complètement refermé et donc visiblement
il ya tout de même une réorientation à
gauche des écologistes aujourd'hui si
l'hypothèse se refermer ce parce que le
modem a pas fait les 5% ce que tu es
d'ailleurs le front de gauche avait dit
dès le début que s'il y avait
possibilité de fusion avec le modem au
second tour le front de confiance serait
pas donc nous félicitons qui n'est pas
une hypothèse mais les verts n'avaient
jamais refusé à l'avance cette hypothèse
de fusion et aux modèles fameuse gauche
rassemblée 1 7l nouveaux mots qui est
inquiète est apparu dans laquelle vous
auriez pu éventuellement vous sentir à
l'aise non mais nous avions toujours dit
qu du deuxième tour nous nous battions
pour battre la droite et donc il y
aurait alliance entre l'ensemble des
forces se réclamant de la gauche et nous
avions dit clairement se réclamant de la
gauche
donc on considère oncle et europe
écologie effectivement dans le camp de
la gauche même s'ils ont parfois à pied
au centre
nous allons contre commencé donc la
semaine lundi dernier c'était pour tout
le monde et sûrement pour vous aussi
recherche des oeufs de pâques dans le
jardin la semaine politique commence
donc au mardi avec les nouvelles flèches
contre le bouclier fiscal oui après les
oeufs de pâques c'est bien la vedette de
la semaine bouclier fiscal le nouveau
ministre du budget françois baroin est
auditionné mardi par les comme ici la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale le nouveau président de cette
commission le socialiste jérôme cahuzac
est très offensif il dénonce un
privilège à 550 millions d'euros pour
0,01 pour cent de la population
française
écoutez la justification du dispositif
par françois baroin et les critiques de
jérôme cahuzac
nous sommes au fond façade de symbole un
bouclier fiscal qui concerne quelques
milliers de personnes
de centaines de millions d'euros ce qui
au regard du budget de la france quitte
assez peu et un impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune isf qui concerne un peu plus
de cinq cent mille personnes pour quatre
milliards et demi ce qui est aussi
relativement peu au regard du budget de
la france donc c'est un débat symbolique
politique puisque nous sommes dans le
symbole est que nous avons besoin de
recul on souhaite plutôt nous côté
gouvernement de stabilité fiscale sur
ces deux sujets il apparaît clairement à
l'issue de cette audition que le
bouclier fiscal ne protège pas les
revenus du travail mais les revenus de
la rente et du patrimoine et donc
justifier le bouclier fiscal pour
manifester exaucé la volonté
présidentielle de ne pas voir les
français travailler plus d'un jour sur
deux pour l'état semble erronée car ce
ne sont pas les revenus du travail qui
sont protégés par le bouclier fiscal
mais bien les revenus et patrimoines la
démonstration en a été apportée de façon
parfaitement claire
alors notez que jérôme cahuzac s'est
rendu à bercy pour un contrôle sur
pièces et sur place et il a relevé
effectivement la nature du bouclier
fiscale du bénéficiaire pour 7 millions
et demi d'euros de ristourne est ce que
vous avez le sentiment que vous êtes en
train à gauche de gagner cette bataille
contre le bouclier
écoutez moi ce que je note c'est quand
tous les cas devant la population il ya
un vrai rejet de ce bouclier a été
interpellé dans la rue en jeu par des
personnes lisant surtout lâché pas
continuer à vous battre contre le
bouclier fiscal parce que dans cette
époque d'injustice on a eu les derniers
chiffres aussi sur les évolutions des
différences entre les très hauts revenus
qui ont vu leur très hauts revenus
augmenter quand même de manière très
importante et les bas revenus qui eux
augmentent peu donc et perlé les
citoyens français les citoyens largement
ne supporte plus ces injustices d'accord
pour hautement symbolique parce que ce
sont des sommes dérisoires par rapport à
d'autres creil à plein de son dirigeant
mais 500 millions ça peut paraître
dérisoire pour quelqu'un qui est au smic
tous les mois c'est pas dérisoire du
tout donc avec 500 millions on peut
quand même faire beaucoup de choses a
simplement à l'échelle des 130 milliards
de déficit public c'est vrai que c'est
pas ça qui va changer les choses hein
mais ça va pas changer les choses mais
c'est un symbole quand même très
significatif c'est que des personnes
quelques milliers de personnes
aujourd'hui on peut décider n'importe
quelle politique fiscale toute façon ça
les concernera pas
même si aujourd'hui un gouvernement
décide par une augmentation de la csg
pour les retraites par exemple elles ne
seront pas concernés et se dire que
c'est on a cette situation quand même un
cadavre est que lorsque plus plus on
gagne de l'argent - o cotisent pour la
santé de tous les deux tous les
habitants de ce pays
à présent la volonté de nicolas sarkozy
qu'un socialiste quelqu'un de
l'opposition préside la commission des
finances que vous reconnaissez que c'est
une quand même une une
nicolas sarkozy lui-même qui promeut
quand même une avancée démocratique
importante où l'on facture la payons
d'appel très lourdement cette avancée
démocratique parce qu'à côté les
pouvoirs du parlement qui devait être
renforcée dans pas été renforcée du tout
ça voilà quand même vous admettez que
c'est une bonne chose pour l'opposition
donne quelques accès à quelques
informations qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir
avant mais quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui l'état de l'ump
qu'effectivement quand même qui tangue
pas mal depuis quelques mois
et du coup le gouvernement ose plus
avoir un seul vote en semaine en dehors
du mardi champ des votes bloqués
tellement il a peur maintenant de perdre
des votes
je sais pas où l avancée démocratique
bon je veux bien que ce soit bien qu' un
socialiste qui préside la commission des
finances mais sera présent aussi faire
jérôme cahuzac tels que le rapporteur
lui ai quand même ump un excès le
rapporteur ainsi qu'à beaucoup de poids
dans le débat sur les finances
alors vous disiez que à certain nombre
de contribuables très riches se trouve
exonérés de tout effort supplémentaire
ça ne va peut-être plus être le cas
puisque françois fillon s'est exprimé au
sénat cette semaine dans la question
dans la séance des questions d'actualité
pour indiquer que les niches fiscales
allait être plafonnés ou réduites elles
vont être placés passé au peigne fin et
au même moment l'elysée annonçait une
contribution pour les retraites
concernant certaines catégories de la
population sous-entendu les plus riches
alors ça c'est un bon signe une réponse
à votre préoccupation écouter sur les
niches fiscales j'attends de voir
puisque on nous l'avait déjà promis
finalement accouché de rien du tout un
port sur le budget 2010 donc
voyons d'abord quels sont les niches
fiscales qui vont disparaître qui vont
être sûrs qu'il y en a beaucoup qu'on
pourra faire disparaître vous avez
jusqu'à qui non seulement sont injustes
socialement mais en plus ce sont des
aberrations écologiques
il y en a aussi qui ont été mises en
place par la gauche au rang
c'est par la gauche je pense pas la
réduction pour les emplois à domicile
elle existait déjà
c'est la droite qui la clé mais sur
cette réduction cette réduction elle
profite largement à ceux qui justement
gagnent le plus sûr que vous ayez des
aides pour la garde des enfants à
domicile
que vous ayez des aides pour les
personnes âgées pour qui est du
personnel à domicile c'est une chose
mais ça a pris une telle ampleur
n'oubliez pas par exemple où vous en
avez pour le jardinage dans votre maison
ainsi vous avez des exonérations pour
cela vous avez des exonérations pour vos
produits informatiques séculier avouez
que c'est quand même invraisemblable
c'est l'ensemble l'ensemble de la
population qui payent pour ceux qui ont
déjà des grands moyens
donc ça c'est quand même invraisemblable
ça c'est une première chose qui est
inadmissible quand on me voit et sur la
taxation pour les retraites
moi ce que j'ai vu aussi c'est qu'il
était question d'augmenter la csg sur
les retraités imposables
s'il faut savoir c'est que le taux de
ces j'ai effectivement différents selon
qu'on est retraité où on est actif et
donc la proposition qu'avait laird est
étudiée par le gouvernement s'était
cette proposition là d'augmenter la csg
sur les retraités imposables
je suis pas sûr que ce soit non plus la
mesure de justice sociale qu'il faille
mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui alors oui
pour taxer les hauts revenus
nous nous sommes au niveau du parti
gauche nous sommes même pour rétablir
les tranches d'impôts sur les hauts
revenus et nous sommes pour plafonner
les revenus il n'y a pas de raison que
des personnes gagnent des millions et
des millions et des milliards même des
fois pour faire quoi pour gaspiller en
plus c'est très mauvais pour la planète
par les temps qui courent ya vraiment
besoin de gaspiller moins nombreux grecs
qui partent à l'étranger
oui pourquoi pas à l'étranger regarder
la politique du gouvernement est
justement monsieur baron a donné les
chiffres finalement il a été obligé
grâce à monsieur cahuzac c'est vrai
finalement il ya eu autant de départs à
l'étranger et pas plus de retour avec le
fameux bouclier fiscal à 50% n'envoyer
que c'est pas ça qui joue sur le fait
que les gens partent on perd pas et
johnny hallyday tueur parvenu à les
mardis encore l'information ou une santé
une information qui vous concerne
directement martine billard vous avez
avec d'autres parlementaires annoncé la
création d'un d'audit sur la politique
d'immigration menée par le gouvernement
votre constat c'est qu'on vous demande
d'examiner bientôt un nouveau texte
alors que les quatre précédents n'ont
pas encore été évaluées n'ont pas fait
l'objet d'une évaluation on regarde
d'abord le sujet de fabrice qu'une haie
ils sont communistes verts socialistes
mais aussi membres de la majorité comme
l'ump etienne pinte
réunis en commission informelle ils vont
mener dans les prochains mois des
auditions pour faire le bilan de la
politique d'immigration du gouvernement
pour beaucoup c'est le signe d'un ras le
bol alors qu'un nouveau texte sur
l'immigration arrive prochainement
devant le parlement
je considère que c'est pas par hasard si
on a eu des débats sur le minaret
l'identité nationale la burqa la viande
halal est maintenant une énième loi sur
l'immigration
il y à un dénominateur commun c'est les
immigrés ou les enfants d'immigrés
j'écoute du coup je considère que c'est
trop leur objectif obtenir les vrais
chiffres notamment ceux du coût des
expulsions 230 millions selon le
ministère près de dix fois plus selon le
collectif cette france-là à l'origine du
projet de contre expertise de l'argent
vt personne ne l'a certainement centre
de rétention et d'en éloigner
si deux parlementaires ump ont pour
l'heure rejoindre la commission
d'autres comme eric raoult route rail
l'initiative
une mission d'information elle vise à
trouver un certain nombre de solutions
est-ce que ça doit coûter moins cher
alors je sais pas les charters ça coûte
moins cher que les billets d'avion
sandrine mazetier est une collègue que
j'apprécie beaucoup mais elle est un peu
atteinte du syndrome de stockholm
c'est à dire à force de travailler
uniquement sur ce dossier de
l'immigration
il faut voir toutes ses facettes la
commission informelle devrait tenir sa
première audition le 4 mai prochain
alors martine billard eric besson a
riposté en annonçant de son côté qu'il
commanda une étude sur le coût de
l'immigration clandestine
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur qu'on en
arrive à une guerre des chiffres est à
l'idée générale quand même cette
immigration clandestine ces clandestins
qui nous coûte cher ce qu'il n'y a pas
un jeu dangereux
c'est justement ce que nous voulons des
montées à ce que ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que toutes ces personnes
qui sont sur notre sol sont des
personnes qui travaillent pour beaucoup
ce qu'on le voit en ce moment il ya la
grève des travailleurs sans papiers donc
qui cotisent quand ils travaillent et
cotisent
mais bien qu'ils cotisent ils n'ont
droit à rien ce qu'ils sont sans papiers
ils payent des impôts y compris moi j'en
ai vu avec les feuilles d'impôts ce
qu'ils essaient d'être dans la légalité
pour essayer d'obtenir leur
régularisation avant lorsqu'avaient ce
type de situation il y avait eu des lois
qui faisait que ces travailleurs
pouvaient postuler à une régularisation
bout de dix ans de présence en france
avec justement des feuilles de paye
ayant payé les impôts ce qui démontrait
qu'il ya une vraie volonté de
s'installer et de s'intégrer
aujourd'hui tout cela était supprimé
donc ils peuvent rester pendant des
années en situation totalement
clandestine si on peut dire mais c'est
pas un coup c'est pas prêt parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous voyez le
bâtiment la restauration la sécurité
pour savoir que beaucoup de sociétés de
sécurité en fait utilisé sans papiers en
toute connaissance de cause donc s'il
n'y avait pas ces travailleurs pour
faire 7 pour occuper ces emplois qui les
occupera aujourd'hui beaucoup de
français ne veulent pas et le royaume
c'est la réalité plutôt se tourner vers
les employeurs qui profite de la
fragilité de nos plus que de ça la
raison mais c'est la question qui est
posée combien ça rapporte de
l'entreprise
parce que ça fait ça
pèse sur les salaires à la baisse n'est
ce pas donc les entreprises notamment
par le groupe bouygues qui a été mis en
cause alors c'est pas lui qui embauchent
directement ces sans papiers c'est la
cascade des sous traitants bien
évidemment chiffre est difficile à
chiffrer
effectivement auditionné toutes les
personnes qu'on peut auditionner si nous
obtenons la mission parlementaire
nous aurons plus de possibilités
d'édition si nous n'obtenons pas
évidemment ce sera un petit peu plus
difficile parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'obligation de répondre à notre
invitation
mais nous voulons vraiment casser cette
idée que les immigrés sont un coup c'est
pas vrai c'est une richesse pour le pays
mais votre votre rapport compte rendu de
ce groupe de travail
ce sera après l'examen du texte besson à
l'assemblée donc sarid arrivé un peu
tard à écouter le froid au plus vite
possible mais il faut le faire
sérieusement donc on va pas non plus
précipitée bon le problème c'est le
texte b sont cinquièmes loin sept ans
mais comme sur d'autres sujets c'est à
dire on fait des lois tous les 6 mois
pratiquement qu'ils me changent jamais
terminé qu'ils sont mal écrite qui ne
prennent pas en compte justement
l'évaluation le bilan des lois
précédentes
bon mais comme ça on fait plaisir à son
opinion publique alors un coup à droite
un coup plus largement il ya un fait
divers ont fait noir voilà on est dans
danger une finale on dévoie la loi
peut-être que c'est face au gouvernement
tous les cas des voix la loi depuis 2002
depuis que l'ump au pouvoir que soit
précédemment avec monsieur chirac ou
maintenant avec nicolas sarkozy il va
pas le temps passé à la journée du
mercredi et la sphère des rumeurs de
l'elysée de vie privée romo public
alors on va tenter de résumer la sphère
qui n'est pas simple un blog du journal
du dimanche qui évoque des rumeurs sur
la vie privée des sarkozy un conseiller
de l'elysée qui accuse rachida dati
d'avoir répandu ces bruits un quotidien
du soir qui affirme qu'une enquête de
police avait été commandé pour savoir
d'où venaient ces rumeurs et on ce
mercredi les deux personnages principaux
féminins de l'histoire entre en scène à
rachida dati et carla bruni sarkozy elle
même qui ont choisi de parler aux médias
anaïs vous bat la fère aurait pu en
rester là mais en confiant ses soupçons
sur rachida dati pierre charon proche
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy lance un
pavé dans la mare selon lui l'ancienne
garde des sceaux serait à l'origine des
rumeurs sur le couple présidentiel
ce matin elle contre attaque
les rumeurs les calomnies les ragots sur
la vie personnelle mais en général sont
absolument inadmissibles et scandaleux
moi je suis en mise en cause
indirectement et c'est tout aussi
scandaleux j'ai n'ai aucun soupçon est
jeune et je n'ai peur de rien cet après
midi nouveau rebondissement le journal
le monde affirme qu'une enquête a été
menée sur ordre de l'elysée là des
séries le contre-espionnage français
auraient été chargés de remonter le fil
de la rumeur l affaire prend une
nouvelle tournure
on utilise le contre espionnage
dans des histoires
sentimentalo romantique entre
le président elle son épouse c'est un
détournement de biens publics un
détournement d'utilisation détourne de
son objectif le contre espionnage mais
vaut mieux vivre en iran
vous avez des choses qui sont claires on
n'a pas loin de penser aux apparent de
parler et à une police de la pensée
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux tandis
que la vod je crois pas que ça soit fait
je n'ose pas y croire
ça me gênait beaucoup finalement c'est
carla bruni qui siffle la fin de la
partie
c'est une première dame déterminer qui
s'expriment sur europe 1 il n'y a pas d'
enquête de police
il n'y a pas d' enquête tout court on ne
fait pas une enquête sur des comminges
donc rachida dati reste votre ami seul
le président il reste tout à fait notre
amie rachida dati reste l'ami du couple
présidentiel
la boucle est donc bouclée selon carla
bruni enfin jusqu'au prochain épisode
martin bien on vous a vu un peu aussi
les sourcils annonce du sujet que les
inspire dans cette affaire qu'est ce que
cela montre qu'ils règlent leur prenne
de couple entre eux qu est ce que les
français ont à voir dans cette histoire
alors c'est une vraiment une mauvaise
pièce de boulevard franchement du
vaudeville est par contre est scandaleux
c'est qu'on utilise effectivement
l'argent de l'état pour ce genre de
choses rachète un prêt semble à une
éventuelle enquête sur qui a répondu ses
fruits les français sont quand même
intéressé par d'autres problèmes la
crise le chômage que l'épreuve de
couples du coup présidentielle puisse
être le couple présidentiel a un peu
trop mis en avant sa vie privée que
c'est un effet boomerang
mais je crois surtout que les français
élisent un président et je lis pas la
femme du président jacques commence à
bien faire tous d'ailleurs pour vous
donner raison au sondage csa disait
vendredi que 82% des personnes
interrogées des français ne se disent
pas influencer par les rumeurs sur la
vie privée des dirigeants publics
ça n'a aucun intérêt car l'intérêt allez
va passer à autre chose alors un martine
billard après les incidents qui ont
touché des établissements scolaires en
région parisienne le gouvernement avait
décidé de convoquer sous les dorures de
la sorbonne les états généraux contre la
violence à l'école luc chatel le
ministre de l'éducation a annoncé des
mesures pour sécuriser les
établissements et préparer les
enseignants à la gestion des conflits
des mesures dont il n'a pourtant pas
préciser le financement reportage sur le
climat général de ces assises est l'état
d'esprit des enseignants fabrice cunay
soixante mille euros c'est le chèque
symbolique des enseignants du lycée
adolphe chérioux pour luc chatel ce
matin soixante mille euros de retenues
sur salaire pour avoir fait jouer leur
droit de retrait c'était en début
d'année suite à l'agression violente
d'un élève dans leur établissement dans
la sorbonne juste à côté deux jours de
débats sur la violence à l'école mais
sans eux et a pas besoin d'états
généraux pour savoir quel est le
problème aujourd'hui suffit d'écouter
les revendications des personnels
enseignants
donc c'est complètement bidon ces états
généraux et je pense que personne n'est
dupe personne ment n'attends rien mais
on est quand même convaincu que le
problème de la violence c'est pas des
portiques ou des caméras des policiers
c'est quand même plus d'encadrement
humain pour les élèves c'est luc chatel
qui a pris l'initiative de ces états
généraux ils réunissent scientifiques et
représentants du monde éducatif et
associatif
leur objectif avancer des solutions face
à la violence en milieu scolaire
quitte à déplaire nous tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est cette importance énorme
on ne peut rien faire sans des équipes
stables mais maintenant la négociation
elle va être complexe j'en ai bien
conscience
1 mais je peux pas dire autrement que
désolé mais c'est la première condition
bon s'il n'y a pas cette stabilisation
là tout sera illusoire
vous pouvez pas penser qu' il faut les
adultes solide en sachant que les
adultes plus ou moins solides change
tous les ans une simple question de bon
sens
depuis vingt ans treize plans successifs
n'ont pas permis de faire diminuer les
problèmes de violence ces états généraux
se veulent le début d'une réflexion
profonde et concertée au lycée adolphe
chérioux
on attend surtout de la cohérence dans
les mesures à prendre
alors justement forme et mieux préparer
les enseignants à d'éventuels conflits
ce une bonne chose
je compte surtout qu'il faut arrêter les
paroles et agir quoi vous savez je
comprends les le fait que les
enseignants soient excédés sur leur
avait raconté beaucoup de choses me vois
rien venir un temps quand les
enseignants ou les entendez dire c'est
des moyens des moyens des moyens de
l'impression que tous les problèmes de
l'éducation nationale se résolvent par
des moyens on sait très bien que c'est
pas en rajoutant des moyens qu'on le
xiii ce genre de questions celles preuve
c'est qu'on peut pas avoir des moyennes
nationales nous ne parlons pas de le
fuir ou à vitry saint lys est très
spécial qui est très très grand avec un
parc et où vous pouvez pas concevoir le
nombre de d'adultes qu'il faut mettre
par rapport au nombre d'élèves de même
manière dans un que dans un
établissement concentré donc c'est aussi
ces moyennes nationales qu'on nous met
constamment kick ass aussi de toute
politique au cas par cas parce qu'il
faut tenir compte de la réalité de
chaque état les effectifs dans les
classes haut niveau sur les essais pas
toujours des enseignants ça il ya eu les
parents comme d'accord pour une
modulation blessures si vous n'avez pas
les mêmes établissements les mêmes
réalités vous n'avez pas forcément me
les mêmes besoins henri iv et au fin
fond d'un d'un lycée de deux cités ça
rien à voir une nouvelle initiative
mercredi autre chose une nouvelle
initiative très perso du patron
turbulent des députés ump cette fois
c'est la suppression de la pub à la télé
publique que jean françois copé en ligne
de mire
absente la pub depuis plus d'un an après
20 heures
elle doit l'être totalement d'ici la fin
2011 mais pour jean françois copé
l'intérêt par rapport au coût de la
mesure est trop faible
il souhaite qu'on en reste là et
organisé un débat sur le sujet à
l'assemblée nationale avec les
principaux acteurs de l'audiovisuel
germain andrieu jean françois copé ne
demande plus d'une proposition de loi
pour maintenir la publicité avant 20
heures mais il persiste
le chef de file des députés ump
proposent la création d'un groupe de
travail
une suppression de la publicité de plus
en plus difficile à compenser
financièrement il en coûterait environ
200 millions d'euros par an
budgétairement ça veut dire que l'état
de fin de compenser c'est beaucoup
d'argent
et en plus je suis pas du tout certain
que ça apporte du point de vue de la
qualité des programmes plus tellement
considérable parce que le vrai plus ça a
été la suppression de la pub pour la
télévision publique dans la soirée donc
voilà c'est à débarquer sur la table je
pense qu'il faut le plancher d'ailleurs
relativement vite pour que les acteurs
sache exactement ce qu'il en est des
professionnels du secteur un peu
déboussolé par le flottement autour de
la suppression de la publicité
les dirigeants des chaînes privées comme
publiques demandent au législateur des
certitudes pour définir leur stratégie
dans les années qui viennent
en particulier un dossier sensible
serait chamboulé par le maintien de la
publicité
celui de la privatisation de la régie
publicitaire de france télévisions la
gauche demande déjà la suspension du
processus
sinon on va se retrouver avec un double
effet d'aubaine pour son acquéreur
potentiel c'est dire stéphane courbit
avec le fait que non seulement il va
récupérer cette régie publicitaire à bas
prix mais qu'en plus il va assurer les
recettes publicitaires de france
télévisions en journée dans cette
affaire c'est le gouvernement qui
devrait avoir le dernier mot
son porte parole luc chatel a indiqué
qu'une suppression totale de la
publicité en 2011 est toujours
d'actualité
alors pour l'instant l'elysée n'a pas
l'air de suivre jean françois copé dans
sa proposition est-ce que c'est passage
finalement de s'arrêter à la suppression
de la pub après 20h dans le contexte
actuel des finances publiques pour pas
avoir à abonder avec le budget encore
france télévisions moi ce que je vois
c'est typique de cette façon de
gouverner de nicolas sarkozy un jour bon
il a une décision et protection sans
même avertir quiconque
il faut supprimer la télévision sur la
télévision publique
donc ensuite charge au gouvernement et
au parlement de trouver la solution
on bricole quelque chose à la va vite
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que ça
a un coût pour les finances publiques
mais c'est ce qu'a dénoncé l'opposition
dès le début c'est personnellement nous
sommes pour supprimer la publicité sur
les chaînes de télévision publiques nous
sommes même pour réduire de manière
générale la publicité dans la société
bon mais ensuite quand on veut le faire
il faut quand même le financer donc
toutes les critiques qui ont été menées
à l'époque on était balader d'un revers
de main par
mp aujourd'hui se retrouve dans une
situation effectivement comment on
finance est bon mais il ya des choix à
faire mais c'est vrai qu'il faut de
toute façon arrêter la privatisation de
la régie publique de publicité parce que
sinon on va se retrouver dans une
situation invraisemblable
comme l'elysée par leur attitude cette
activité cette suractivité du président
du groupe ump jean françois copé qui
multiplie les groupes de travail et qui
parfois 20 l'encontre des de la
politique de l'elysée et du gouvernement
mais surtout il va aussi à l'encontre
des pouvoirs du parlement parce que moi
je remarque que l'ump vite
systématiquement les missions
parlementaires de maintenant il ya des
groupes parallèles de travail de l'ump
ce qui fait que les députés ump vont de
moi j'aime bien les émissions beaucoup
de missions sur la mission contre les
violences faites aux femmes à niamey le
président le rapporteur qui était ump
est autrement n'a pratiquement pas vu
les députés ump c'est vrai à peu près
dans toutes les missions donc ça sert
conséquence journée de travail en
parallèle donc par ce cas là je sais pas
que jean françois copé a jusqu'au bout
propose la suppression de l'assemblée
nationale parce que tel que c'est parti
on arrive à peu près c'est le
gouvernement et l'assemblée de l'ump
points puis pas de bruit pour la
démocratie
allez on passe maintenant à l'actualité
de jeudi un verdict à nouveau très
douloureux pour les victimes les
victimes de la tempête xynthia
oui c'est une nouvelle journée terrible
pour certains sinistrés de la tempête
xynthia ce jeudi il découvre la liste
des zones noires établies par les
préfets de vendée et de
charente-maritime dans ces deux
départements très exactement 1393
maisons vont être rasées
car construites en zone hautement
inondables kamal abdou rain un zonage
critiques et des indemnisations dans le
flou et une absence de dialogue
les réunions publiques de ce matin n'ont
pas convaincu les victimes de la tempête
xynthia ce sinistre et habite l'une des
zones noires décidée par l'état est
amené à disparaître
il souhaite que l'état soit à l'écouté
de leurs revendications je suis très
surpris je suis très déçu nous sommes
les premiers concernés et on a été mis
de côté dans ce travail c'est pas
correct mais c'est ainsi et donc si
cette décision nous convient et bien me
convient tant mieux si elle ne nous
convient pas nous prendrons les
dispositions pour la contester hier les
élus avaient été mis dans la confidence
les chiffres sont importants
près de 1400 maisons rasées 915 en
vendée et près de six ans en charente
maritime les zones noires sont arrêtés
c'est au noir sans compagne et deux
zones jaunes à la terre des zones jour
nous regardons les cas individuels mais
les zones noires ont été définies et
dreux étaient définis après un travail
d'élaboration très complet dans lequel
nous avons entendu tout ce qui devait
l'être
le fonds barnier créé pour l'occasion
s'élève à 400 millions d'euros
mais certains habitants craignent une
indemnisation au rabais la plupart sont
allés coûte mais certains préviennent
quoi qu'il arrive ils ne quitteront
jamais leur maison ce matin dominique
bussereau tenter de prévenir les
incendies
c'est un trait de plume 1 je je je je
vois j'ai joué à le travail des mères
avec les préfets cetera
il ya des études qui se poursuivent dans
sa tombe de communes s'est pas fait
comme ça c'est tellement grave que s'est
fait sérieusement et rien n'est encore
figé pourra y avoir certains
accommodements si des études montrent
que pour telle ou telle maison on peut
trouver d'autres solutions d'autres
solutions pour des habitants qui après
le choc de la tempête pourrait bientôt
subir celui de l'expropriation
d'ores et déjà des voix s'élèvent pour
demander une révision au cas par cas des
zones noires décision expéditive et sans
concertation c'est ce que dénoncent les
habitants et même les maires moi ce que
je vois surtout c'est que les habitants
finalement sont victimes d'une double
peine ils sont pas responsable du fait
qu'on ait autorisé à construire dans des
zones qui n'aurait jamais dû être
autorisé à la construction c'est là où
est le vrai problème ce sont des soldats
ont été construites il ya très longtemps
mais ça change rien vire l'homme n'est
pas au dessus de la nature contrairement
à ce qu'on croit on croit toujours qu'on
va pouvoir faire face à l'internât et
donc c'est un peu le problème c'est
qu'on a beaucoup de retard en france par
rapport aux zones inondables avec les
plans de protection ne sont toujours pas
appliquées dans le pas mal de communes
ne sont toujours pas voté y compris où
ils sont toujours pas opposable alors
c'est douloureux
il est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
mais par contre ils doivent être
indemnisés totalement parce que
justement ils ne sont pas responsables
l'état doit couvrir lancé les
municipalités qui ont été irresponsables
franchement mais vous le savez très bien
où il est très difficile quand on nous
en tant qu'écologiste on a toujours dit
qu'il fallait être responsable et oser
dire qu'on pouvait pas construire
n'importe où on nous traite de tous les
noms je rappelle que nicolas sarkozy le
lendemain de la tempête expliqué qu'il
fallait délégiférer et il prenait comme
exemple le fait qu' il fallait justement
assouplir les conditions de construction
et d'autorisation de construction donc
on voit le résultat ce que ça donne là
où ça y est quand même instruction pour
que dans ses couloirs beaucoup de morts
c'est pas évident d'aller dire on va
plus construire ma maison c'est pour ça
qu'ils savent hauteur du littoral dit
qu'il faut que les habitants soient
totalement indemnisés pour pouvoir
reconstruire ailleurs parce qu'ils ne
sont pas responsables des décisions qui
ont été prises alors à noter aussi les
premières auditions cette semaine pour
la mission d'information du sénat sur la
tempête xynthia
elle a notamment entendu jean louis
borloo le ministre de l'écologie aussi
le président de la fédération des
assurances bernard spitz avec 10
notamment dans les discussions de cette
mission le plan digues pour reconstruire
les digues en france ça c'est quelque
chose qui sur lequel vous vous comptez
pour protéger à la fois le littoral et
même les cours d'eau si tant est qu'on
ait les moyens de les reconstruire ces
digues alors un oui moi je pense que
toute façon il faut nationaliser les 10
entre guillemets nationaliser parce que
preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a des
digues qui sont des digues d'état des
dix qui sont l'éthique des collectivités
et on a même des digues privé donc il
peut pas y avoir déjà de plan d'ensemble
de maintien et d'entretien de ces
niveaux là le même problème en camargue
a donc ça il faut absolument maintenant
que les digues reviennent à l'éveil
cléda soit une compétence détail qui est
en soit responsable mais qu'il assume
bien évidemment mais il faut aussi
savoir que oui les digues peuvent être
une solution mais ne peuvent pas
toujours l'être il faut pas penser qu'on
va pouvoir mettre des digues partout non
il ya des endroits où la mer reprendra
ses droits parce que le bas voilà
la nature j'ai été plus forte que celle
de leur lit ce qu'il faut changer pour
qu'ils aient plus de construction dans
ces endroits là normalement se voulait
il ya beaucoup d'endroits où devrait pas
y avoir que de construction mais on
détour l'on contourne un peu les
interdictions contre le mal est fait
qu'il ya beaucoup de constructions de
bord demain que fait on écoutez il ya
des endroits où effectivement on peut au
que construisit qui protégeront il ya
l'autre en français qu'il s'est dit que
nous ne pourrons pas faire face en
captant peine de la puissance de xynthia
donc dans ce cas là il faut mettre en
place des solutions pour reculer
vous savez que la mer grignote le
littoral dans le nombre de points notre
territoire et il faut commencer à avoir
des plans de recul par rapport à par
rapport au littoral et gercées par une
planification nous on appelle ça la
planification écologique on peut le
faire en faisant en sorte qu
effectivement il n'y ait pas deux pour
les personnes qui se retrouveraient sans
logement mais qu'elles soient relogés ce
soit assumée par la solidarité nationale
encore un dossier que vous suivez
attentivement ce jeudi était présenté à
l'assemblée le texte du grenelle 2 qui
va bientôt être examiné par les députés
ce texte est déjà passée au sénat il a
été examiné donc en commission par les
députés et en commission l'opposition a
voté contre
on est bien loin de l'unanimité du
grenelle 1 jérémy hartmann ce sont eux
les travailleurs de l'ombre du grenelle
veut des députés ump chargé de
synthétiser tout le travail effectué en
commission en tout 55 heures de débat et
619 amendements adoptés comme
l'expérimentation d'une taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères la
mise en place de schémas régionaux de
l'éolien ou encore l'expérimentation
pendant au moins un an de l'affichage du
coût carbone des produits à compter du
1er juillet 2011
un ensemble de mesures qui pour autant
ne fait pas oublier l'abandon de la taxe
carbone
c'est vrai que c'était un signal dont on
aurait pu on aurait pu se passer quand
il ya des points vraiment très très durs
d'achoppement il est pas bon lit pas
inutile de faire une pause bon c'est le
cas de la taxe carbone j'aurais préféré
évidemment qu'on donne un signal le plus
fort dans ce domaine ça n'a pas été le
cas et la suspension de cet emblématique
taxe carbone a valu à la majorité de
perdre un allié de poids
il y a dix jours c'est nicolas hulot et
sa fondation qui décidé de se retirer
des ateliers de travail du grenelle de
l'environnement
sentiment de gâchis la commission rocard
il ya eu tout processus du grenelle
il ya un travail de fond et puis il ya
eu un travail je dirais de sap un peu
systématique des uns et des autres sur
cette mesure est une mesure complexe
délicate qui demande énormément de
pédagogie qui devait précéder tout une
réforme de la fiscalité
c'est dans ce climat d'écolo-scepticisme
que débutera début mai l'examen du
grenelle 2 plusieurs fois reportée les
débats ne devront pas durer plus de 30
heures selon la nouvelle réglementation
de l'assemblée nationale il faudra donc
faire vite et bien
et cette fois ci sans le soutien de
l'opposition qui avait voté le premier
volet du grenelle en octobre 2008 soit
pas été mieux sur ce genre de sujet
d'affiché n'ont pas eu d'unanimité mais
quand même un accord sur la question
j'ai un accord fac et des mesures dignes
de ce nom
mais le problème c'est que déjà le texte
n'était pas brillant n'en pousse a été
complètement grignoter en commission
donc il ya des vrais recul qu'on était
qu un lieu par exemple sur l'éolien
suite au rapport de la mission et aux
liens cirquenbul is et les
préconisations en fait vous rendez
compte que derrière c'est finalement
avantager le nucléaire le rapport de la
mission repris donc par amendement sur
le grenelle 2 impose des obligations
éolien qui n'ont jamais été imposée
nucléaire par exemple comme de pré
financer le démantèlement des éoliennes
à venir diront justement problème du
nucléaire ce qu'on n'a jamais prêt
fumeurs n'a jamais provisionner le
démantèlement à venir des centrales
nucléaires et là on n'est pas dans les
mêmes sommes pourtant bon les schémas
qui veulent être imposées sont des
schémas tels que on va plus construire
d'éoliennes en france donc on est dans
des contraintes sur tout ce qui est
justement mesures environnementales qui
n'ont jamais été fait ailleurs par
contre là où il pourrait y avoir des
avancées par exemple sur l'étiquetage
carbone
mais ce normalement ça devait rentrer en
vigueur pour gaza comment les produits
sont arrivés sur un décalage et combien
ils produisent un projet
d'expérimentation
alors c'est plus une obligation donc sa
vie ce qui va se passer parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les grandes
marques nous ont dit que nous mais vous
savez où il commence à y avoir beaucoup
de choses sur les emballages on a pu la
place d'écrire bon c'est pas un hasard
s'ils sont tes conseils le consommateur
a plus le temps de rire donc oui mais ça
on peut le mettre
grand choc sur les paquets de cigarettes
vous avez en gros fumer tue bon bah si
vous mettiez en vous mettiez en gros là
qu'on calcule carbone
j'ai eu tant qu'il reste ça se voit donc
comme ça ça permet aussi aux
consommateurs de faire des choix parce
que si vous les parents que même sur les
produits bio c'est bien de manger bio je
suis pour mais si vous avez un produit
qui vient de l'autre bout de la planète
en termes de bilan carbone c'est un
désastre et ont salé ne le comprennent
pas toujours ça coûte cher aussi un
vivre bio c'est un luxe
ça dépend où c'est pas toujours le cas
mais si c'est vrai qu'il faut éviter
d'entrer de ton front de gauche suis sûr
qu'on est plus sensible au surcoût des
produits bio qu'à leur production ces
quelques heures les câbles lartigau je
vous tromper totalement ça ne nous est
pas un hasard si on a mis comme devise
socialiste république écologie parce que
ses vêtements les trois piliers et donc
au contraire nous sommes pour développer
le bio mais justement si on développe
massivement en france
ça fera chuter prix les produits bons
aujourd'hui la porte 1 aujourd'hui on
importe la majorité donc c'est pour ça
aussi que les produits sont très chers
et c'est très mauvais au niveau du bilan
carbone bella hulot a eu raison ne
claqué la porte du grenelle 2 après
l'abandon de la taxe carbone jean ou la
taxe harvard ont été contre ce contre
cette taxe carbone considère qu'elle
était injuste socialement inefficaces et
que je vais pas payer les entreprises
polluants voilà absolument et en plus
juste un petit détail comme ça qui est
significatif c'était censé changer les
comportements dont des français et veut
les pousser à réduire l'utilisation de
la voiture et à changer leur mode de
chauffage d'un parent sur mode de
chauffage chez vous à voir c'est que les
locataires paient quand même la taxe
carbone qui était récupérée dans les
charges sur les locataires ans le
locataire est responsable du chauffage
l'isolation de son logement
donc ça c'est significatif du fait que
c'était pas effective fiscalité en
revanche dans le réel mais que c'était
une volonté de faire entrer première
brique de lait oui c'est l'abandon du
projet de texte n'a pas été modifié
puisque c'était la volonté du conseil
consommer c'est impossible
c'était impossible parce que
effectivement ce gouvernement n'est pas
taxer les entreprises qui en 2013 seront
soumis au marché carbone mais avec
européens mais avec en plus ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'il ya quand même des
gros problèmes sur ce marché beaucoup de
spéculation ça marche et le talent d'une
taxe européenne
frontières c'est ce que défend nicolas
sarkozy mais ça c'est effectivement plus
intéressant c'est qu'ils font pas ce
qu'il faut pas oublier c'est d'ailleurs
sorti dans un médium je ne sais plus
quel c'est intéressant qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que beaucoup de nos
produits que nous importons sont donc
produits par an en chine à des coûts
environnementaux très élevé mais à des
coûts de salaires faibles donc ce qui
nous permet de payer moins cher en
france mais qui en fait ensuite on quand
on dit que c'est la chine qui aimait
beaucoup de co2 est ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'une partie des émissions de co2
en chine sont en fait de vraiment fait
nous est attribuée à nous pays riches
parce que c'est pour permettre à nos
pays riches ne pas avoir ses émissions
de cendre dans le pays parfois
françaises sont délocalisés ont
délocalisé faut toujours y intégrer
voilà on existe nos pollutions ailleurs
carbone mais beaucoup plus réfléchis
beaucoup plus foncée et à l'échelle
européenne et qui permettrait donc de
relocaliser les productions et du coup
avoir des contraintes environnementales
dans nos pays riches et en même temps du
coup d'aider les pays du sud plus pour à
pouvoir intégrer ces procédés qui serait
moins désastreuses pour l'environnement
voilà cette semaine a été marquée
également martine billard par un bras de
fer entre les départements et les
conseils généraux c'est un autre dossier
particulièrement offensive
la seine-saint-denis présidé par le
socialiste claude bartolone
il a fait voter par son conseil général
un budget en déséquilibre ce qui est
illégal pour pointer le défaut de l'état
qui selon lui ne compense pas comme il
se doit
l'explosion des dépenses sociales que
doit assurer le département les
explications de flora sauvage rmi rsa ap
à autant de prestations sociales qui
plombe les finances des départements car
réforme après réforme l'état ne compense
plus financièrement le transfert de
charges opérés depuis les lois de
décentralisation de 2004
du coup le département de
seine-saint-denis est au bord de
l'asphyxié et ils s'apprêtent à voter un
budget en déséquilibre
je fais pas l'aumône je dis voilà les
dépenses que j'applique sur le
territoire au nom de l'état les
différentes allocations pour les
personnes âgées pour les personnes
handicapées le rmi rsa qui relève de la
solidarité nationale et ce qui relève de
la solidarité nationale
doit être payé dans le cadre de la
solidarité nationale d'autres
départements sont aussi touchés en saône
et loire le président du conseil général
à couper dans les dépenses touchant aux
sports à la jeunesse ou à la famille le
but arriver à boucler son budget on l'a
pris des mesures drastiques de réduction
des crédits et nous assumons en plus
l'impopularité de ministres quittent de
la république qui viennent sur nos
territoires dire que nous on est en
quelque sorte des réducteurs de service
public
à notre tour en fait le pouvoir vous
oblige à faire du sarkozysme par
procuration aujourd'hui on est
complètement étrangler financièrement il
y à 20 du département qui sont les
premiers touchés
il y en a ras 16 l'année prochaine on a
emprunté de l'argent
jusqu'où on pouvait le faire mais demain
on sera incapable d'équilibrer nos
recettes et nos dépenses cette année un
certain nombre de départements s'en sont
sortis en augmentant les impôts ou en
renonçant à des investissements mais
l'inquiétude est de mise
y compris dans les rangs de la droite
région et département martine billard
détenu majoritairement pourra par la
gauche ont l'impression que c'est un
procès très politique qui est fait à
l'état hélas non puisque vous savez même
le président du département de haute
loire quai donc divers droite qui lui
dit aussi que ce n'est plus possible
parce que l'état ne compense pas les
transferts notamment de politique
sociale qui ont été faites vers les
départements et les régions sont
similaires pour ce qui est des routes et
d'autres transferts qui ont été faits
dont il ya un vrai problème de manque de
recettes pour les collectivités locales
aujourd'hui qu'elles ne peuvent pas
compenser sauf à augmenter les impôts et
on va terminer avec la journée du
vendredi c'est normal avec une page
judiciaire qui s'ouvre à france télécom
après donc la vague de suicides france
télécom le parquet de paris décide
d'ouvrir une information judiciaire pour
harcèlement moral et ce à la suite d'une
plainte déposée par le syndicat sud dans
la ligne de mire notamment l'ancien pdg
de l'entreprise didier lombard
jérémy hartmann pour le syndicat sud
c'est déjà une première victoire
avant d'ouvrir cette information
judiciaire pour harcèlement moral la
justice s'est appuyée sur la plainte du
syndicat et sur le rapport de
l'inspection du travail remis en février
médecins du travail caisses d'assurance
maladie tous ont multiplié les signaux d
alerte auprès des dirigeants sur la
santé des travailleurs
en ligne de mire la politique de
réorganisation et de management menée
depuis 2006 par france télécom c'est une
stratégie folle c'est à dire que on a
décidé à un moment donné qu' un nombre
important des milliers des dizaines de
milliers de personnes devaient quitter
l'entreprise
on a donc artificiellement créés des
situations de détresse mentale de
souffrance au travail et les
conséquences et bien entendu des départs
ils sont allés au delà de ce qui était
attendu par la direction mais les
conséquences aussi ce sont des troubles
psychosociaux ce sont des dépressions et
ce sont les suicides dont la presse a
beaucoup parlé cette enquête est une
première elle ne visera pas les
dysfonctionnements ou les négligences
mais bien l'organisation du travail dans
son ensemble
prochaine étape la constitution des
parties civiles
le syndicat sud lance désormais un appel
aux autres organisations syndicales et
aux familles des victimes